l'espace avec cette frayeur
rétrospective la nasa vient d'annoncer
qu'un astéroïde grand comme un terrain
de football a frôlé la terre il y a six
jours à quelque cent vingt mille
kilomètres de distance seulement il n'a
été repérée qu'ensuite les spécialistes
considèrent réellement qu'une
catastrophe a été évitée de justesse
robben bonnan un astéroïde long comme un
terrain de football fonçant vers la
terre à plus de cent mille kilomètres
heure c'était il ya une semaine mais sur
le moment les astronomes du monde entier
n'ont rien vu ce dangereux rôdeur venu
de l'espace
surnommé 2002 elle n a été repéré quatre
jours plus tard après avoir frôlé notre
planète
à seulement 120 mille kilomètres soit un
tiers la distance de la terre la lune
un scénario catastrophe évitée de
justesse les plus graves un peu plus
exceptionnel c'est effectivement les
dangers qu'ils peuvent avoir avec la
tête par très proche
c'est l'équivalent en propre les plus
d'e10 mégatonnes qui tombe cela tu as
donc d'énergie assez important et donc
il peut avoir un changement look à la
recherche - cas pas son appétit
catastrophe locale sous la terre si la
collision avait eu lieu les dégâts
auraient été comparables à ceux 10 908 à
l'époque un astéroïde équivalents
avaient dévasté deux mille kilomètres
carrés de forêt en sibérie à risque
heureusement très limité d'abord parce
que les trajectoires des plus grosses
supérieur un kilomètre de long sont
connus et ne présentent pas de danger
ensuite pour les autres un tel choc ne
se produiraient d'après les calculs
qu'une fois tous les dix millions
d'années